in the past three weeks more than 70
people have been killed in mass
shootings
the most recent at a medical center in
tulsa oklahoma
where four people were murdered by a man
said to be a disgruntled patient police
say the gunman then killed himself he
bought one of his guns just a few hours
before we know
through the help of our atf
and their gun tracing that at 2 pm
on june the first
mr lewis purchased
a semi-automatic rifle
from a local gun store
the same weapon was used to kill 19
children and two teachers at a texas
elementary school last week
the same weapon used to murder 10 people
at a grocery store in buffalo new york
10 days before that
in both cases the alleged gunman were
just 18 years old the texas shooter
killed at the scene the buffalo shooting
suspect was arraigned on murder charges
thursday
in a rare prime time address to the
american people president biden urged
congress to impose federal gun controls
suggesting a ban on automatic weapons
and high capacity magazines
raising the age at which an individual
can buy a gun from 18 to 21
and removing the protections against
litigation enjoyed by gun manufacturers
they had one message for all of us
do something
just do something
for god's sake do something some of
these measures suggested by president
biden are already being debated and may
well be passed in the
democrat-controlled house of
representatives
but they're likely to be blocked by
senate republicans who were a particular
target of president biden's anger but my
god
the fact that the majority of the senate
republicans
don't want any of these proposals even
to be debated
or come up for a vote
i find unconscionable
we can't fail the american people again
a message too for the american people
that the majority should act and turn
their outrage into making the issue
central to their vote
mike hannah al-jazeera washington